chinese president xi jinping has made a
pitch for a peaceful stable and
prosperous afghanistan on the second day
of talks with taliban leaders the talks
being held in china also include
representatives from regional nations
such as russia pakistan tajikistan iran
and some others it's being seen as an
attempt by beijing to play a leading
role in the region while guiding the
future of a country with strategic
significance for itself and its
neighbors
we'll talk more about that in a bit but
here's a quick look at what xi jinping
said
i quote a peaceful stable developing and
prosperous afghanistan is the aspiration
of all the afghan people it is also in
the common interests of regional
countries and the international
community
and for more on this i'm joined from
vienna by valena chakarova she's
director of the austrian institute for
european and security policy and one of
europe's top experts when it comes to
geopolitics involving china and russia
marina i intend to look at both those
countries in a moment but first i'd like
to drill down further into china's role
in afghanistan what is china trying to
do here with these latest talks
so obviously uh the things shifted
towards china filling the geopolitical
void
left by the u.s withdrawal last summer
and china
is uh intending to do this in two
particular tracks on the one side of
course
by engaging with the taliban that means
a political dimension where they need
desired talks let me remind you that
even though that they do not uh still uh
recognize the taliban they of course are
politically dealing with them and did
not actually leave the country following
the takeover uh the second of course
track is the economic one and here the
goal is clear china wants to incorporate
afghanistan into its
broader jewish strategic projects in the
region
to link it to pakistan pakistan has this
pakistan china economic corridor and in
the next step it will be also iran uh
pakistan afghanistan
so here the incentive is clear
already 62 billion were offered to the
taliban for uh various projects now most
nations involved in these talks felina
particularly china russia and pakistan
have concerns especially to do with
terrorism emanating from afghan soil how
do they plan to address them with the
taliban
well in two possible ways the one of
course direct by offering them
incentives by incorporating afghanistan
into geo-economic projects uh
china's also seeks to uh relaunch mining
activities uh they want to
let the taliban take care of the
security problems the indirect way the
second way is by cooperating with the
central asian countries and specifically
by russia china will meet russia as a
security provider on the ground which is
uh by the way happening russia also did
not leave the country last summer and in
fact is
is a kind of uh engaged in a modus
vivendi with china to deal with the
afghanistan problem it's a diplomatic
boost for moscow but it's also a huge
security boost for china to deal with
these problems collectively so jointly
so that means of course also using
regional organizations such as the
shanghai cooperation organization to
involve the central asian republics and
of course they will engage with pakistan
pakistan has
been offered a lot of economic
incentives by both
russia and china and of course pakistan
has a direct influence on afghanistan
and of course it is that close
cooperation between russia and china
that we also want to look at uh
villeneuve because foreign ministers of
both these nations sage lavrov and bangi
met on wednesday and reaffirmed the no
limits partnership that their leaders
had agreed to in february let's just
quickly hear what sage lavrov had to say
during this meeting
we are living through a very serious
stage in the history of international
relations
i am convinced that at the end of this
stage the international situation will
be much clearer and that we together
with you and with our sympathizers will
move toward a multi-polar just
democratic world order
melina a just democratic world order now
that's that's two adjectives that are
sort of hard to reconcile with russia's
actions in ukraine aren't they i mean
what is sergey lavrov saying here
what uh sergey lavrov is implying is
that russia's war on ukraine
marks the beginning of cold war 2.0
so now we are in a situation where these
the west versus the dragon bear
bifurcation of the global
affairs has become a reality
and of course the centrifugal forces are
now
also involving all relevant regional
actors such as india such as the
indo-pacific nations but also other
parts of the world
for instance
think of this brics summit that means
also latin american countries african
countries and all of these regional
players are right now kind of
oscillating between the west on the one
side we saw 48 countries uh who uh
introduced uh severe sanctions on russia
isolated russia following february 24th
but then again we see a lot of
countries
which are not seeking to the sanctions
which try to somehow avoid this binary
world they are facing
and this is what uh lavrov is now
actually
implying on the one side obviously
china
has sided with russia the dragon bear is
a modest event of systemic coordination
and has been in the making since 2014 at
least that means following the first
invasion of ukraine by russia but now of
course the mosques are off and here we
talk also about i ideological uh
competition as well that means also the
way
they uh understand and read
international
rules norms and also the way their
understanding of governance
is uh going to be shaped so speaking of
cold war 2.0 are you saying that there
is no room particularly in asia let's
just talk about asia there's going to be
no room in asia or the indo-pacific for
fence sitting somebody countries are
going to have to pick a side is that
what you're saying
in the long run right now we we are in
this
so volatile transitionary period uh
which is uh uh linked to a lot of
insecurity there are so many critical
uncertainties right so some countries
like australia for instance
did take a site uh this is what
australia did last year by uh entering a
security and defense pact and i argued
that in the long run a lot of regional
players in the pacific will be faced
with the same dilemma of either or
choices uh some countries like
india are going to probably uh
seek once again a very unique position
in this
rapidly shifting global orders so that
does not necessarily mean only uh siding
with the west but i suppose that india
will try to navigate carefully between
these two
emerging geopolitical blocs yeah william
just briefly where does that leave the
united states i only ask because the
special representative of the united
states is going to be part of a meeting
with china russia and pakistan today
ostensibly on afghanistan but i'm
certain that ukraine will also figure
prominently here won't it
exactly this troika format uh has been
uh
working uh so that means this one of the
opportunities for the american and the
russian counterparts but uh of course
the chinese one will be also present to
meet and discuss the relevant uh
issues of uh the international relations
and ukraine will certainly be on the
agenda even though the detroit the
detroit discusses actually afghanistan
let me also remind you that there's been
a severe famine emerging in afghanistan
so there is also a humanitarian crisis
and because of the
severe second order effects now emerging
out of russia's war on ukraine that
means uh specifically wet exports to uh
the middle east and to uh north african
countries but also asian countries and
one of these uh examples is afghanistan
there'll be there will be certainly also
a discussion on how to tackle the
humanitarian crisis and when it comes to
ukraine i do not anticipate any kind of
approximation of the position so on one
side of course united states is uh
strongly behind ukraine and is going to
do everything uh possible to of course
strengthen ukraine's defense forces
together with the european union members
and other trans atlantic allies and
partners and on the other side as i said
we are seeing these dragon bear models
with ending diplomatic but also
political economic and uh
and other issues
william we leave it there for the timing
but thank you so much always a pleasure
talking to you
you